All right.
Soon a federal judge is expected
to release the names
of dozens
of Jeffrey Epstein's
alleged victims and associates.
And now comedian Jimmy
Kimmel is threatening a lawsuit
against New York Jets quarterback
Aaron Rodgers
for insinuating
without any evidence at all
that Kimmel's name
might be in those documents.
This is what Rodgers said
in a radio show.
A lot of people,
including Jimmy Kimmel,
are really hoping that as
we
again, we didn't play to amplify that.
We played it so you could see
what was said here.
Kimmel responded,
saying in part, For the record,
I have not met, flown with, visited
or had any contact whatsoever
with Epstein,
nor will you find my name in any list
other than the clearly phony nonsense.
The soft brain wackos like yourself
can't seem to distinguish from reality.
Your reckless words
put my family in danger.
Keep it up
and we will debate the facts
further in court.
Now, clearly,
CNN no one
has any reporting
that Kimmel is linked
in any way to the Epstein case.
There was some bad blood, it's
notable between Aaron Rodgers
and Jimmy Kimmel because of jokes
that criminal Kimmel had made
criticizing Rodgers for pushing
conspiracy theories.
Here now, CNN legal
analyst and criminal defense attorney
Joey Jackson.
Joey,
the reason I want to do
you want to talk about
this was the issue of defamation.
You know, what Aaron Rodgers said
has no basis in fact,
no evidence to support it.
When does something like
that become defamation
here, John?
Important questions
to be answered for sure.
So what happens is, is remember
what defamation is.
It's a false statement
that is injurious
to someone's reputation.
And as a result of that,
it can cause the person
great reputational damage.
When you talk about defamation
as it relates to public
figures, as both Jimmy
Kimmel and Aaron Rodgers are,
you have to show
what's called actual malice.
What on earth does that mean?
You have to show knowledge
that you made the statement
knowing it was false
or just reckless disregard
as to whether it was false or true.
So it's a very heightened standards.
At the end of the day, though,
I don't think it's yet ripe,
ripe for any defamation claim.
Certainly no one would want to be listed,
talked about in the same sentence.
Right.
In terms of.
EPSTEIN
But when you talk about defamation,
one defenses is absolute truth.
If in the event it's true,
it may be a terrible thing
that someone said, but you know what?
It's not defamatory.
The list hasn't been published yet.
And so we'll see not to suggest at all
that anybody's name,
whether it be
Kimmel and Rogers,
would be on that list at all.
But, you know, it's not ripe yet
to the extent
that when the list is published,
everyone will get to see for themselves
who specifically is on it, John,
and who's not.
Well, when Jimmy Kimmel, as he says
his name is not on that list, does it
then become a legal issue
that Aaron Rodgers said it
without any basis, apparently whatsoever?
So so here's the issue with that.
Right.
Remember that
if defamation
is to end your reputation, certainly
you shouldn't be saying anything. Right.
That is injurious to anyone,
whether they be public
figures, private figures
or anything else.
The problem with defamation
in that regard, though,
John, is this follows
let's just say he's not on the list.
That is Jimmy
Kimmel was not on the list
as he suggests.
He would never be on such a list.
Then the world would know
that this is just a bad blood argument.
And you can argue
that if you're Jimmy Kimmel
that it's injurious to your reputation
because in essence, you're cleared
as a result of a list being published
to show that you're not on it.
So I don't see any reputation
reputational damage there.
As you mentioned at the outset,
there's no love lost between them.
Kimmel has made some jokes
about Aaron Rodgers
that he has not appreciated,
including how he's worn that
his and Rodgers, his hair.
And so they've gone back and forth.
And I think the public may
just take that as this
and not anything in terms of,
you know, mean spirited
or to rise to the level.
Well, you can argue it's mean spirited,
but to rise to the level of defamation.
You know, start
Jimmy Kimmel in his social media theme.
He did point out,
if you continue this, basically
I will see you in court.
So
if Aaron Rodgers
were to say anything else,
how would that contribute
to possible legal
jeopardy or civil liability?
Yeah, sure.
So it would depend upon what is said.
Right.
Ultimately at the end of the day. Right.
And you have to look
at everything in context.
I think the argument will be made right.
The context of this,
of course, is that Jimmy Kimmel,
when he makes his comments
and statements,
it's comedic in nature
not to suggest comedians
can injure someone.
They certainly can,
particularly when you have a platform
like him. So too.
And Rogers has a tremendous platform
and you have to be careful
about what you say.
And so to the extent
that there is no such list,
that includes Jimmy
Kimmel and Aaron
Rodgers would pretend you
to continue to propagate that.
Now it could rise to the level
because he's not there,
that it's now alive.
Remember what defamation
is, just a reset, right?
False statement
that is injurious to your reputation.
You keep repeating something,
you keep repeating something.
Guess what?
In this world,
people get to believe it's true.
Now, you may have a cause of action,
but I just think it's a feud
between two people
who probably
have had enough of each other.
Joey Jackson, we appreciate it.
Thank you very much.